>> A VETERAN RUSSIAN DIPLOMAT
WHO PRESIDED IT MAY, PROTESTING
WHAT HE CALLS MOSCOW'S
AGGRESSIVE WAR AGAINST UKRAINE,
OF COURSE VLADIMIR PUTIN CALLS
A SPECIAL OPERATION.
BORIS BONDAREV WAS POSTED TO
RUSSIA'S MISSION TO THE UNITED
NATIONS IN GENEVA, AND IN A
STATEMENT ON LINKEDIN, HE WROTE,
QUOTE, THE AGGRESSIVE WAR
UNLEASHED ON BY PUTIN ON
UKRAINE AND OF COURSE BY THE
ENTIRE WESTERN WORLD IS NOT
ONLY A CRIME AGAINST UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE, BUT ALSO PERHAPS THE
MOST SERIOUS CRIME AGAINST THE
PEOPLE OF RUSSIA.
BORIS BONDAREV JOINS ME NOW THE
ESCAPE.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
THANK.
YOU EXPAND ON THAT IF YOU WILL.
WHY DID YOU RESIGN IN FEBRUARY?
AND WHAT DID YOU MEAN IN WHAT
YOU WROTE?
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELL, IN SHORT, I RESIGNED
BECAUSE ON FEBRUARY 24TH THIS
YEAR, MY COUNTRY ATTACKED
UKRAINE, OUR NEIGHBOR COUNTRY,
I WOULD SAY OUR BROTHER COUNTRY.
ALWAYS THOUGHT ABOUT IT, MOST
RUSSIANS.
THAT WAS A THRESHOLD FOR ME.
I REALIZE THAT I CANNOT ANY
LONGER STAY IN THE CIVIL
SERVICE.
I CANNOT ANY LONGER PROTECT
THIS, YOU KNOW, THIS WAR.
I ENDURED FOR THIS --
I DID NOT LIKE WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
I TOLD MYSELF EVERY TIME THAT,
OKAY, AS FAR AS THERE IS NO
VIOLENCE, AS FAR AS THERE IS NO
WAR, I CAN PUT UP WITH IT.
THE WAR IS SOMETHING TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
>> WERE YOU SHOCKED?
I'M INTERESTED TO HEAR IF YOU
WERE SHOCKED BY PUTIN'S
DECISION ON FEBRUARY 23RD, 24
TO INVADE.
OR WAS IT TELEGRAPHED TO YOU AS
AN AMBASSADOR, SOMEONE WHO
WOULD HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS?
>> NO, OF COURSE IT WAS NOT,
BECAUSE THIS DECISION WAS
EVIDENTLY TAKEN IN THE
ATMOSPHERE OF HIGH SECRECY.
EVEN OUR MILITARY, WE WERE
STATIONED ALONG UKRAINE BORDER,
WE DID NOT KNOW UNTIL THE VERY
DAY OF THE ATTACK ABOUT THAT
THAT WE WOULD BE ATTACKING
UKRAINE.
OF COURSE, IT WAS A SHOCK FOR
ME, AND SO MANY PEOPLE WHO
STAYED IN THE UNITED STATES
INTELLIGENCE, WE SAID THE
INVASION WAS IMMINENT, YET I
DID NOT BELIEVE THAT PUTIN
WOULD DO THAT.
BECAUSE WE ALL OF THE PROBLEMS,
THE THEY HAVE CONSEQUENCES
WHICH WE WOULD ASSUME --
I DID NOT SEE ANY BENEFIT THAT
RUSSIA COULD GET FROM THAT.
I DID NOT BELIEVE IT AT THE
TIME.
OF COURSE, I WAS SHOCKED BY THE
INVASION.
>> AND SEVEN AND A HALF MONTHS
IN, AND WITH THE LATEST NEWS
THAT PRESIDENT PUTIN HAS
ANNEXED, THESE FOUR REGIONS,
YOU MUST HAVE BEEN WATCHING
THAT VERY ELABORATE CEREMONY AT
ST. GEORGES HALL IN THE KREMLIN
ON FRIDAY.
WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH YOUR
MIND, WHAT WAS HIS STRATEGY
HERE?
>> WELL, THIS SPEECH WAS, IT
WAS A COMPILATION OF ALL OF THE
CONSPIRACIES THAT WE CAN NOW,
IT COULD NOW BE FOUNDED IN
THEIR RUSSIAN SOCIETY.
IT IS ABOUT THIS WESTERN,
DETERMINATION TO DISMANTLE AND
DESTROY RUSSIA, AND SO ON.
EIGHT IS ALL, NOTHING TO DO
WITH REALITY.
AND YOU KNOW, TO WATCH THE
SPEECH, IT WAS VERY PAINFUL.
FOR ANY INTELLIGENT PERSON.
WITH THE STRATEGY --
WHAT IT'S TRYING TO PROMOTE, I
DON'T THINK IT HAS A NEW
STRATEGY.
BECAUSE THE ONLY STRATEGY HE
HAD WAS TO OCCUPY ALL OF
UKRAINE IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
AND THEN THIS, FROM THE
POSITION OF STRENGTH, POSITION
OF CONQUER.
SINCE HE APPEALED IT BACK, NOW
THESE TRADITIONS, SO TO SPEAK,
IS TO FIND A WAY TO GET OUT OF
THIS POSITION.
AND HIS SITUATION IS GROWING
WORSE AND WORSE EVERY DAY.
OVER THE WEEK AND, PUTIN ALLY
AND LEADER OF THE CHECHEN
REPUBLIC --
PAD YOUR OFF CALLED ON LATTIMER
POND TO TAKE MORE DRASTIC
MEASURES.
INCLUDING THE USE OF LOW YIELD
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
GIVEN HIS RECENT LOSSES ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, DO YOU BELIEVE
VLADIMIR PUTIN COULD, WOULD,
WILL, ACTUALLY, RESORT TO THE
USE OF THESE SORT OF NUCLEAR
TACTICAL WEAPONS?
OR WORSE, AT THIS POINT.
>> I BELIEVE THAT HE MAY TRY TO
DO SO IF HE FEELS THAT HE IS
FULLY CORNERED.
THAT HE HAS NO WAY OUT.
AND I THINK IF UKRAINE IS TO
CONTINUE THEIR MARCH TOWARDS
TEMPORARILY OPTICAL --
OCCUPIED LANDS AND I THINK THAT
MR. PUTIN WILL FEEL THIS VERY
SOON.
AND --
BUT FOR NOW I DON'T THINK THAT
THE RECORD OF HIS USING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS FOR TODAY IS QUITE
HIGH.
I DON'T THINK IT'S HIGH, BUT IT
MAY BE HIGHER.
IT WILL ALL DEPEND ON THE
COURSE OF THE WAR.
AND IF THE NEWLY POPULARIZED,
SO TO SPEAK, ARMY TARA, IS TO
CRUMBLE AFTER A FEW SERIOUS
BLOWS FROM UKRAINE.
AND THEN WE'VE HEARD THAT THERE
ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO SURRENDERED
AND MANY PEOPLE WHO DROP THEIR
GUNS AND FLEE FROM THE
BATTLEFIELD, THIS RUSSIAN ARMY
MAY STOP ITS ATTACK SOON.
THEN I THINK THAT MAYBE NO ONE
WILL BE THERE TO EXECUTE THESE
ORDERS IF THE ORDERS WILL COME
FROM PUTIN.
AND I THINK OF THE RUSSIAN ARMY
WILL BE DEFEATED BY UKRAINIANS,
THEN PUTIN MAY FACE SOME
OPPOSITION WITHIN HIS OWN INNER
CIRCLE.
SO HE MAY EVEN NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT TIME TO RESORT TO
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THAT IS MY HOPE.
>> THAT'S FASCINATING.
HE USED HIS SPEECH ON FRIDAY TO
JUSTIFY THE WAR WALTZED CALLING
FOR A CEASE-FIRE OR A PATH TO
PEACE.
DO YOU GENUINELY BELIEVE THAT
HE WANTS TO ISSUE PEACE AT THIS
POINT?
AND, SHOULD, GIVEN THE POSITION
ON THE BATTLEFIELD, AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S MOVES TO
ILLEGALLY ANNEXED PARTS OF
UKRAINE.
SHOULD UKRAINE AND THE WEST
PURSUE HIM, HIS CAUSE FOR PEACE
AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, I BELIEVE THAT BY
PIECE MR. PUTIN UNDERSTANDS
PEAS ON HIS OWN TERMS.
AND THOSE ARE LIKE UKRAINIAN --
SO TO SPEAK, FOR UKRAINE TO
SURRENDER TO RUSSIA.
BUT PUTIN WILL NOT GIVE UP HIS
NEWLY OCCUPIED TERRITORIES.
IT WOULD MEAN UKRAINE LOST THE
WAR.
AND WITH THAT, THE WESTERN
COUNTRY, NATO WILL BE
HUMILIATED.
WHICH IS ANOTHER GOAL FOR MR.
PUTIN.
AND THEN, THE GLOBAL POLITICAL
LANDSCAPE OF THE PLANET WILL
CHANGE VERY SIGNIFICANTLY.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S THE
OUTCOME THE WESTERN COUNTRIES
SHORT STRIVE FOR.
>> RIGHT --
SO, CAN I ASK YOU --
>> YES.
>> I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU, BECAUSE
OF OUR BREAKING NEWS, I WILL
HAVE TO LEAVE THIS, BUT I JUST
NEED TO ASK YOU THIS ONE
QUESTION.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS VULNERABLE AT THIS
POINT?
>> I BELIEVE THAT AT THIS POINT
HIS POSITION, IN RUSSIA, IS
WEAKER THAN IT WAS BEFORE.
AND HE GETS WEAKER EVERY DAY.
BUT I DON'T SAY THAT WE SHOULD
WAIT SOME LIKE COUP OR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
IT IS NOT A MATTER OF WEEKS.
I THINK IT IS A MATTER OF
MONTHS, RATHER.